A good way to get started with such a problem is to write out what sorts of strings are matched.
There are things like 1 space 1, 1 space 123, because of this plus, 2 space 456, and so on.
One of the things that we notice quickly is that they all have a space,
they all start with a single digit, and they don't have any letters in them.
Is a1 space 2 part of the possible return value?
Well, it would have to match this regular expression and be in the string.
It's in the string but it doesn't match this regular expression,
because it starts with an "a" and none of our things start with an "a."
How about 1 space 2? That looks pretty good.
We have 1 space 1, and we could pick a different digit, and it's in the string.
It could be a part of our return value.
1 space 2b--it is in the string, but we never have any letters in this regular expression.
It doesn't match.
2 space 3--this has the right format. It matches our regular expression.
But it's not actually in the haystack string, so it can't be part of the return value.
44--this has the wrong format. We need a space in the middle.
3 space 44--this has the right format, it matches our regular expression,
and it actually occurs in the string. Great.
3 space 44d--this has the wrong format. Again, we're not matching any letters.
So just these two.